the live and Alive tour is off and
running St Louis I will see you on
August 4th and 5th La local show here
August 11th Tampa Florida August 18th
and 19th with Steve Simone Springfield
Missouri September 1st and 2nd Tulsa
Oklahoma September 15th and 16th Phoenix
Arizona September 29th and 30th Salt
Lake City I'll see you all October 27th
and the 28th in San Francisco California
I'm coming back December 8th and 9th get
your tickets to all shows at
ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it and night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and as always I want to say
thank you thank you to everybody that
has to find this show because YouTube
likes to demonetize us and pull us out
of the algorithm because we talk about
real things over here and that's all
right when you see us you hit us you
subscribe it's a huge way to help the
show and push it back out there
um and look I want to just tell you this
too if you gotta have more than you've
got to have the patreon I'm telling you
listen for five bucks you don't just get
one episode you get the entire back
library or getting an audio and video
you're also getting this show the
Honeydew a day early no ads at no
additional cost it's five bucks all
right if you don't like it kill it all
right you get it for a month anyway so
you're gonna get at least four depending
on how many weeks are in that month five
episodes you know what I'm saying it's
like a dollar an episode and you're
getting the Honeydew with y'all and it's
the most insane stories you could you
can't imagine I promise you I promise
you so thank you for those of you out
there that do support the patreon I know
there's a lot of new subscribers there
you guys are the you're the best if
you're looking for a new podcast to
listen to then go check out my old
podcast the crab Feast again everybody
you know and love in podcasting is on
that show with different stories it's a
generic storytelling show with some of
the most fun stories you've ever heard
out there I promise you that also on
tour all right back's feeling better
lungs are feeling better we're gonna
start getting out there a little more
all right we've got dates through this
year we're gonna roll all the way next
year as well so August 11th Los Angeles
local show we're gonna do a night in
Flappers uh out in Burbank All Right
tickets are on sale for that now August
18th and 19th Tampa Florida I'm coming
finally coming to Florida my boy Steve
Simone will be with me we're gonna have
a great show down there come out and see
us September 1st and 2nd is Springfield
Missouri never been to Springfield
Missouri to do comedy so I'm fired up to
come there and then September 15th and
16th is the Tulsa that was the one that
had to be rescheduled because they
weren't open yet so all tickets are live
now on my website go get
emryancesickler.com now
that's the biz you know what we're doing
over here we're highlighting the low
lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers and I am
very excited to have this guest on today
for the first time here ladies and
gentlemen Alex Hooper welcome to the
Honeydew yay jump here it does feel
really good to be here I'm glad listen
man I first of all thought you had
already been on here and you're like nah
dude that was the crab fee so go check
out his crab feast episode because it's
a great we're just talking about how you
got attacked by a zebra at a zoo that's
the kind of stories we're gonna hear
over there
um well thank you for being here because
uh I didn't want to make a big deal of
it but this is our you're gonna be the
last guest in this studio oh my God Burn
It To The Ground everyone and as soon as
we watch everybody here get the kerosene
yeah I went everywhere
um I don't know I don't make big deals
of a lot of things but I am excited
we'll show you guys we got we're moving
to a new studio so uh thank you Santa
Monica music center we're just uh
outgrew the space we're gonna go to a
bigger spot uh because we've got some
new exciting things coming your way that
we'll get into later but anyway you were
here please plug promote Alex Hooper
everything yeah um you can find me on
the road hoopercomedy.com got a bunch of
tour dates coming up especially starting
in August I'm hitting it very card uh
Hooper hair puff are on my social media
and then I have a podcast weekly it's
called Dirty briefs it's uh 15 minutes
or less of whatever the [__] I feel like
doing that week sometimes it's positive
affirmation sometimes it's a list
sometimes it's just me being a goofy
[__] idiot however I feel like it but
yeah just something to get myself out
there every week
all right so look we've known each other
for a while now we did Baltimore
together got the tailgate at the Ravens
game I had a good time got our got our
as the game I think we all left in the
third quarter we got our hands
um but some people come on here they
tell a life story you actually have uh
something to talk about so you got
married in April of 20 2022 2022. all
right so April last year yep so you just
in a year oh just barely over a year
yeah we've been together happy
anniversary yeah thank you we've been
together since College it's been a very
long journey for us like Tech we've been
in together in some form or another for
18 19 years and so what made you finally
say let's do it now you know my I had a
very Antiquated view on marriage because
my parents my mom and stepdad are both
divorce lawyers so I grew up thinking
marriage was the worst thing you could
ever do I never had a positive outlook
on it really were they married did you
do well for a little while and they got
divorced they're both uh they had two
divorces and three divorces under their
belt simultaneous so like that's all I
knew and they were divorce lawyers yes
so they're just wrapping themselves in
there like I'm just gonna do this I
think the only reason my mom and stepdad
never got a divorce is because they were
both afraid the other one would take all
of their own like the other one's money
like that they were both so talented at
their job but when you grow up like that
all you hear is like oh this dad sucks
and this mom's trying to take her kids
and blah blah so I was like this is I'm
never doing it but my wife got me to the
point where she was like look you're
looking at the wrong examples why are
you looking at our parents for like look
at our friends that are married and have
perfectly happy lives like we should do
this and we knew we wanted to have a
family so I was like okay I just need to
get over my own [__] and get there
and something that really got me there
is this there's this Alan Watts quote
that's uh you have no obligation to be
the person you were five minutes ago and
when I heard that my brain was like
wow I'm holding on to so much inner
turmoil from when I was a child that I
don't even believe anymore I just need
to let this [__] go so I proposed and we
got married in a beautiful wedding in
Puerto Vallarta Mexico oh yeah I've been
there it's beautiful now yeah all right
it's fantastic thanks so that's April
2022 and then shortly after that you
start noticed some weird health issues
yeah so then over the over the next
couple months I was extremely busy and
so I was just kind of ignoring what was
going on inside of me but I noticed my
neck started to like really like thicken
up people would see me be like are you
working out a lot and I'm like no and I
couldn't stop touching like my in the
neck area was it sore it wasn't sore I
could just feel these things in there I
know it makes you want it because I know
I'm like are they getting here are they
in here so then I'm at a music festival
and I'm I'm on I'm tripping on acid that
and I saw suddenly was like something is
wrong with me and my brain is like
telling me like I'm in this trip but I'm
going like you need to figure this out
when you get out of this Festival so I
get out of the festival I go to the
doctor a week later my doctor looks at
me is like I think there's lymphoma
and I was like what just write like that
that's what she said she said I think
this is lymphoma you need to go get
tested I'm going to send you to a
specialist and that started a
three-month journey of getting every
test you could possibly imagine to test
for basically they were like you have
cancer we just don't know what kind wow
they basically they knew pretty much
right away that this is a type of cancer
we gotta go figure it out now so what
what is the do you know I don't want to
put you on the spot the difference
between I I always hear Leukemia and
Lymphoma linked together yeah at least
mentioned together I should say do you
know the difference I believe leukemia
is a blood cancer blood okay and then
lymphoma is like when you're lymphobic
nerds your lymphatic nerves so the
reason I so when I was by the time I got
all my testing done and I had ever I
mean MRIs pet scans blood work I had a
bone marrow aspiration what is that dude
so they basically to see if it's stage
four they have to extract cracked bone
marrow and they they got a needle this
big now here's how you know you're about
to be in a lot of pain if there's four
people in a room for one person one for
each limb two of them but they're
literally just to hold me down and they
do it through your hip oh dude in the
side like in the side oh yeah and they
gotta numb me up or something they do
but you can't numb bones that's what you
learn really so they're numbing the skin
to break the skin but the bone is the
bone dude when it gets you but you will
physically just go like this like oh and
it's the we the weirdest pain you have
ever felt because it's this deep just
like pinching how long how long are they
in there it was like six seven minutes
holy [__] dude I thought you're gonna
say it was like in and out no because
the doctor he even said to me he's like
you have very hard bones very hard bones
and I was like I don't need this right
now I'm getting roasted about my bones
get out of here and it turns out I
didn't have stage four so yeah I had
stage three which means it had spread
from my lymph nodes in my neck all the
way down to my pelvis essentially so
they found it everywhere but it took
three months to get myself to that point
they were like it's Hodgkin's lymphoma
stage three what does that mean
Hodgkin's what is that because then I
hear Non-Hodgkins as well all I know is
that Non-Hodgkins is apparently less
treatable I don't actually know the
difference between Hodgkin's and
Non-Hodgkins
um but what makes it Hodgkin's is there
something that makes it that or is it
always Hodgkin's lymphoma no there's
because there's different kinds of
lymphomas but I don't
I
mean I don't know nearly as much as I
probably should considering that I've
gone through it and I lived in it every
day for about 12 months but there's some
things where you're like
part of me was like it doesn't matter
what it is it's in me and I have it and
I just need to get rid of it and
honestly the testing period that was the
worst when you don't know what's wrong
with you you just know something it's
terrifying because you don't know how to
tell your family you don't really know
what's going on inside of you once they
told me hey it's stage three Hodgkin's
lymphoma here's what we're gonna do to
get rid of it this 12 rounds of
treatment over the next six months chemo
no radiation I was like so you can get
it they're like oh this one yeah 90 for
someone your age 95 cure rate and so you
hear that and you're like great okay
then get let's let's go and I wasn't you
know this is one of those things where
it came into my life and there's nothing
you can do about it so you just start to
figure out like okay well how can I
learn from this experience and how can I
get through it in a way that doesn't
completely deplete me from who I am and
so I started doing chemo and
chemotherapy was fine to the point where
let's pause for a second yeah go for it
how just I mean here's what's crazy how
relieved are you first of all because
are you thinking the entire time this is
a death sentence 100 because my body I
have dealt with Healthcare issues my
entire life I have one of the worst
cases of eczema you could imagine where
a doctors my whole life have just looked
at me and said I'm sorry
yeah and I'm like you're a I don't need
your sympathy here man like I need you
to fix me when I was a kid I would
literally have pus oozing out of my face
I would wake up in the morning stuck to
my own pillow ah like it was off I mean
my skin I looked like a hot dog that was
run over by a car it was just brutal a
painful uncomfortable so I'm no stranger
to health issues and my body it always
goes to the extreme it always like if
and so I was like oh it's gonna be stage
four there's no way my body wouldn't
allow me to get anything less than a
stage four and so part of me was live
stage six
there was not even a five you skipped
right over that into six you're just
hurdling over stages
it's it really I really expect them to
say it and part of me goes oh I'm not
afraid of I'm not afraid of death I'm
not afraid of death what I'm afraid of
is complete attrition of my body
deterioration that's the thing that
scares me the most I think also too when
I think about it like
I guess I either assume or or naively
hope all the time that I'm gonna make it
in my 80s
you know especially in this business
this business is not not for longevity
you know what I'm saying and if I can
make it there then I'm not scared of
death I think the thing about death for
me is I'm scared of of dying before what
I feel is my time you know what I mean
it's taken yeah you know and and you
know not to compare in any way but I had
a death scare as well so you know you
start thinking about all those things I
mean also you just got married yeah you
just got married and you wanna and the
reason you finally got over all that was
to start a family and this may be the
end of your life yeah but the thing
about that was it was if I'm dead I
don't know any better in my opinion like
I'm not one of the I don't know what
happens after you die like I don't I
don't claim that I don't think about it
really so my thing is I'm not afraid of
when it's over because I don't think
I'll know any better I'm afraid of
living in a way with no quality of life
where everything is painful every
you're just breathing and alive you're a
heartbeat that's the scariest thing for
heartbeat yeah I'm with you and that's
what I don't want so death was never it
was like when they were like hey this is
pretty serious I was like okay like and
I kind of just like reconciled with how
was your wife with it though
I think it's worse for her yeah I think
it was I think the entire experience
everything I went through which we'll
get into in a second of how bad it gets
is I think the person next to you is
always going to have the harder
challenge because they have to watch you
go through it
standing there they have to answer to
every doctor she's the one taking the
notes because when they tell you hey man
you have stage three Hodgkin's lymphoma
your brain goes
and you disassociate immediately and
you're just sitting there going uh-huh
okay and my wife's the one like taking
every [__] note like making sure that
we know what's happening she's also the
one that has to deal with my family her
family all of our friends she has to
answer all the questions this is like
your cancer concierge you know
get that I checked in and I made sure
top of the line service please do that
for cancer patients and families a legit
cancer concierge where they just cater
to your situation and help your family
out and all the answers this is the
brilliant idea yeah does anyone also
take the stress off of your you know
your wife or whoever that might be
that's helping you though it's yeah
because it's so confusing the first of
all just our medical oh system here is
confusing enough then you gotta then you
gotta mix whatever your issue is into
that medical world and figure out how to
work that I mean it's a nightmare so
yeah man so you're lucky you had her
there so lucky she was there every step
of the way she refused to miss an
appointment she runs her own business we
have two dogs like she has to take care
of a household of business all that
stuff and now all of a sudden her
husband is lethargic he depressed scared
like ever all of the things of like all
the things that basically make me who I
am were suddenly Stripped Away because I
became a shell of who I was I didn't
know how to move forward but when the
chemo started I started to feel a little
bit better everyone said like hey it
made me really knock you out it didn't
knock me out in fact I went to every
chemotherapy session like where people
were like it's gonna be scary I went in
going I'm ready give it to me give me
the medicine that will clear the [__]
out of me and get me back to my [__]
life because that's when I found out I
had cancer all tour dates have to stop
oh everything has to stop everything and
because if it doesn't your [__]
life's about to stop yeah yeah and I do
think I was going so hard when I first
when I didn't know I had the cancer
inside of me I was going very I was like
attacking life like as hard as I could
between like doing my own work partying
traveling all of the things that wear
you down I was doing to myself so
everything's going great through chemo I
would like literally get chemo and then
go play tennis and do a show at night to
the point where I looked so healthy that
people were questioning whether or not
it was real and I was like what a
terrible [__] bit really people some
people said that to you oh yeah oh of
course it's wild to me that anybody
questions that I remember
um
I think his name was Quincy that also
had cancer Quincy Jones and and yeah and
they questioned that as well yeah well
because people have an idea of what
cancer should look like and if I
ultimately should do to someone yes and
it's like if you don't die did you even
really have cancer yeah that's what I
can't Quincy yeah I mean yeah you got
some of that I got what I got is after
shows people were like is this real like
you don't look like you they would say
this to you yeah and I'd be like yeah
I'm not making this up wow they say to
somebody they just don't understand when
someone is attacking cancer like right
in its face where like I'm talking about
it I'm making jokes about it I don't
look sickly at all so to them if they've
known if they've seen cancer in their
own life or like someone maybe their mom
had it or something they were like you
don't look like she did like there's no
way you happen and that's what that goes
through their mind so they're trying to
reconcile their own brain if he looks
this healthy BDS cancer you hadn't lost
hair or anything like that at that point
nothing nothing and that I think what
they were thinking is if he looks this
healthy and he has cancer do I have
um here's where it all falls to [__]
[Laughter]
as if it was good at all because cancer
was just such a light in my life it was
just so wonderful I'm like oh I guess
you just take a break and have people
take care of me
um here's where it starts going downhill
so two months after my new chemo it's
I'm getting it every two weeks a couple
hours for an infusion uh after my fourth
session
I had felt great and suddenly I started
to feel really beaten down and I got
back from a show at the Irvine Improv
and I was like shaking violently when I
got home and my wife was like are you
were you like this whole time and I was
like no I just didn't feel really good
she's like go to bed because well we're
seeing your doctor on Monday anyway this
is like a Thursday I start can't I wake
up the next day and I'm so out of it I
start canceling all my shows for the
week I'm just like I've never and I've
never canceled anything I'm one of those
people it's like I will show up if I'm
[__] dead and I was like there's no
way I can perform I just can't do it so
I have to cancel shows see my doctor on
Monday
Monday comes and I have to go get a pet
scan to figure out where we are in the
treatment process and when I go there I
am completely Delirious I had seen my
doctor that morning they put hot they
put fluids in me it said go get the Pet
Scan go home take a Vicodin and just
take a nap and we'll see you very soon
so that I go get the Pet Scan I don't
remember any of this
I go home I go to sleep
it's 4 P.M I wake up at 8 p.m I walk out
of the bedroom my wife is sitting on the
couch watching TV I walk into our
kitchen
just start taking a piss
and my wife if you don't remember this
this is being told yeah my wife turns
around she's like Alex no what are you
doing you can't pee in there and I was
like oh I'm I'm sorry yeah yeah you're
right and so I walked into her office
and pissed all over the wall no yeah
just all over it I did my business in
the place where she does business like I
went in there and just soaked the
[__] place and so she comes in there
and she's like oh my God okay just okay
go to the bathroom uh
take off your clothes
um okay just like you're soaked I and so
I don't know what to do she calls our
two of our best friends
um who have known like I officiated
their wedding these are very very close
friends of ours they come over
immediately and
they find me basically she had put some
clothes on me so I was just clothed
enough but I when they came over I was
so out of it my friend Mike was like I
need you to sit down and I looked at him
I was like how
and he goes there's a couch behind you
just put your butt on it and I'm like I
don't know how to do that
they realize I'm in a very bad State
take me to the emergency room at which
point when I get to the emergency room
they're asking me check-in questions and
they go what's your name I don't know
you don't know I don't know what year is
it I don't know who's the president uh I
don't know now to be fair the president
doesn't know who the president is that's
true but it was one of those things
where they immediately checked me in and
I'm out of it I don't remember any of
this part of the process I have very
faint like flashes of memories but
essentially then I get into the hospital
they start running tests on me and
here's where here's what I finally
eventually learned a few days later
my portacath which is the port that they
put in to do chemotherapy they do a
surgery to put it under your chest so
you don't even think about it it's just
in there it never has to like you know
be worried about getting wet or anything
two months after they did it it got
infected and I don't know it's infected
because it's an internal infection that
infection spread to my heart causing a
one centimeter vegetation what so and
after and I'm going to slowly try to
explain what these things are because I
didn't even know I have to I had to
research all this a vegetation is a germ
or mass of cells in your heart that is
not supposed to be there and it blocks
our ankle block arteries and what it
will do is then that can spread and move
one of two ways and go to your arms or
your legs or it can go to your brain
mine decided let's go see what's in
Alex's brain and figure that out so it
spread to my brain which was causing
multiple embolisms to happen at the same
time so essentially why you don't know
who you are what's going on it's RDS
yeah that's what has happened already
happened I'm having a long-term stroke
something's wrong here but hey just like
I just kind of feel all right everybody
like just not losing my mind had no idea
and then basically what happened is I
had formed I had gotten sepsis
and sepsis is your body's extreme
reaction to an internal affection where
it causes tissue damage and your organs
start shutting down so when they took me
to the hospital
I was essentially hours from Death whoa
hours that's what they told my wife when
I got there and they checked me in and
they put me in my in a room and
everything they told her you need to
brace yourself this is extremely serious
and we don't know what's gonna happen
and my wife is terrified obviously we
had Frozen sperm before I started doing
the chemo because we knew we wanted to
have a family she had a full-on
conversation with one of her sisters of
if Alex dies do I have his child because
I have what would you want her to do
[__] no really
no
no for sure sounds like the most
depressing every time you look at it and
like what if what if this kid's a
horrible kid you're like yeah of course
it is Alex Alex was a terrible child
why'd I do this to myself like the idea
of me living on through a child is like
if I if I'm there for the child's life
I'm gonna be a dad sure but like oh no
having to explain that story when
they're like nine years old like why
don't I have a dad well here you go you
know
it's I I don't think I would have wanted
that I don't know if she she I think she
did I think she was all kind of like for
it but so that started the process of me
I was in the hospital for 33 days
you go in completely out of it having no
idea what's going on with you and I
didn't see the Sun for 33 days and how
long were you in for yours was what 30
just about 30 yeah right it's beautiful
though yeah after after nine days I had
a window but it was a first eight to ten
days I didn't I had a window but it
still was like and I would sit by it
sometimes but for the first two and a
half weeks I was completely bedroom oh
yeah my body swelled up 25 pounds from
edema which is basically just your
body's unable to release water so I
didn't I didn't go to the bathroom for
the first nine days I was in there I was
barely eating anything either but like
all like I had like a tube that's like a
catheter and everything but I was my
body just filled up to the point where
everything hurt all the time okay so can
I ask you this then if now we're having
to Pivot from lymphoma to take care of
this what's happening to lymphoma while
this is happening so we have to stop
treatments all together I'm assuming
because my body was in such a weak in
state they have to fill it with
antibiotics and stuff and chemo is just
getting rid of everything right
including all the good the white cells
too so now long is the game plan how
long is it before we get you right
before we can go back to attacking
lymphoma this is when I had at this time
I went from having one oncologist to
having seven Specialists a day visit me
to make sure okay let's check his lungs
let's check his heart let's check this
let's check this every single thing and
my doctor my oncologist is like I need
to get back in there and like get rid of
the rest of this lymphoma like we were
doing really well and then I have
infectious disease specialists going
you're not [__] going near this guy
right now he's gonna die if you get in
there and so everything was like it
paused essentially for treatment because
all it was was we need to save this
guy's life and Rehab him to the point
where he can get back on treatment to
Safe continue saving his life it was
the it's like it's affling to think
about because I consider myself a pretty
healthy person I exercise I eat well I
do self-care things and so all of a
sudden everything in my body is just
going no no we don't feel like it
anymore just [__] you you know that's
how it felt it felt like my everything
was turning on me
so then what happens how long is it to
get you cleaned up and and back into
um treatment for lymphoma so I was so
the 33 days in there
um they're trying to deal with the
sepsis and that whole time is just the
sepsis and the the infection 30 through
all 33 days yes until they did a full
month off of chemo correct and when I'm
in there they're doing they're doing
multiple procedures every day like MRIs
and pet scans and everything else MRIs
by the way I was I've done MRIs in my
life the claustrophobia doesn't bother
me it does a lot with a lot of people
because it's so loud
volume it's the space yeah when you're a
broadcaster yeah yeah something I was
able to relax in there except when I had
the edema they would twist my leg and
they would need to stay in like one
position for 45 minutes there were
multiple MRIs I screamed cried through
the entire experience because like there
was nothing else I could do to release
the pain yeah then just cry hard I I
just had this time I wore a dark eye
mask and put air pods in and outside the
tunnel smart so that way I never saw the
clothes you know what I mean I just
listened I just saw Blackness and music
and just they slid me in and I was like
how long is this guy's like I can do it
in eight minutes if you stay still I was
like nice done yeah I had a few that
were very very long I had some 20
minutes that I just I can't it's brutal
it's terrible it's you know and I'm
being pumped up with Dilaudid like every
couple hours and I knew like it got to
the point where like they were giving me
so much Dilaudid it was barely even
affecting me and I was like like and
that's I mean I love my drugs and so I
but I couldn't even enjoy the Dilaudid
there was like it was basically like
because you were on that too right yeah
for me there was a 10 seconds as soon as
they injected it and I was like oh is
this why people do heroin is this a
Chasing the Dragon for this 10 seconds
where you go uh
okay yeah but see I I didn't get that
that's what people loved I didn't get I
was terrified on it yeah like what it
did do though
um two things it's a physical for me
it's physical and mental the physical it
absolutely took the pain away so I was
in so much pain that it took the pain
away it didn't make me high it just made
me feel better physically but mentally
I'm telling you like I'm looking at you
right now and just flesh chunks your
face or falling off and hitting the
table and bloody strings are hanging
there I wish I had that I'm seeing the
cheekbone that's what everybody says
I've made them taking them
get this [__] out of here I don't want
this at all no that was yeah mine was
more so just like it was just
maintenance it's all it was is like make
some of this pain go away but there was
no Euphoria from it which also with all
the mental anxiety going on it's it just
wrecks everything yes you're not having
a ball in there no it's oh it's all the
thing is I can't even my brain is so
loopy that I can't even read a book I
can't do anything except lay there and
watch TV when I finally started doing
physical and occupational therapy in
there I would do three hours a day and
it was such a reprieve but I was so
weakened that I the first time I tried
to get out of bed my first physical
therapy session I couldn't even get out
I could not stand up I could I sat up
and so dizzy yeah and weak I fell back
and they're like you can't do this today
yeah and that's kind of that was my
thing too is that you forget that you're
laying there so long your body atrophy
is very good oh my God it's wild how
fast it happens yeah so fast I felt like
there's old people in cocoon when I got
out first I could touch my hamstring and
it would just shake my ass was gone I
feel like I got a nice little baseball
ass yeah I definitely have about 50
years old I got a nice little baseball
ass I could still fill out a pair of
baseball pants Oh baby but uh it was
gone it was gone it's almost back now
from Physical Therapy but it was get
those squats on there right oh my hip
hinges and get my squats yeah I thought
so I they told me I'd been in there like
27 days or something like that and they
were like hey you're gonna get out
tomorrow and they were we just have to
do one up more MRI they do an MRI and
realize that I have an old injury in my
knee from 20 years ago where I had
pulled and I tore an ACL and my Meniscus
and they were like you don't know about
that and I was like I mean I remember it
happened 20 years ago and but like I
don't feel it anymore and the doctor was
like well your knee's not draining from
the edema it was like four times the
size of my left knee he's like we need
to get in there and we need to do a
surgery tomorrow and I'm gonna be
walking around without that those
tendons and [__] for all this time yes
and you dude I mean so you know me I
slack line yeah I tightrope boy for
hours at a time and I think that's the
reason why I never knew that I never
felt knee pain is because I've
strengthened and rehabbed myself to this
point where I have I have work on
muscles that I don't even know exist but
now they have to do this surgery so it
drains properly yeah hair changes can
happen due to age biology and lifestyle
no matter the root cause of your hair
concerns neutral full meets you exactly
where you are with science back formulas
tailored to your needs while
neutralfolds hair growth supplements
Target the root causes of thinning hair
from a thin neutral scalp Care Formulas
help create a healthy environment and
for improved hair quality the shampoo
scalp mask and scalp Essence are each
gentle yet effective in work to
exfoliate purify and balance the scalp
for improved hair Health the sulfate and
silicone free shampoo and conditioner
are designed to cleanse the scalp
without stripping neutrophils physician
formulated scalp care products are
clinically shown to balance the scalp of
physically improved hair health and
strength in two weeks with their 100
percent natural fragrance zero parabens
and ingredients that are color and
extension safe take the first step
towards improved hair and scalp Health
now for a limited time neutropholes
offering our U.S listeners ten dollars
off your first scalp care order when you
go to nutrifol.com scalp and enter promo
code honeydew find out why over 4 000
Health Care Professionals recommend
neutralfold for healthier Hair
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com slash scalp and
enter the promo code honeydew for ten
dollars off your first scalp care order
this is available only to U.S customers
for a limited time that's neutrifold.com
scalp promo code honeydew for ten
dollars off your first scalp care order
our next partner is athletic greens I
heard about athletic greens and decided
to give them a try because my energy and
my immune system could both use a little
boost it's become part of my morning
routine which means I'm starting every
day feeling like I'm doing something
great for my body more than just greens
it's all your key Health Products like
multivitamins minerals pre and
probiotics and more working together as
one it's made with 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients that deliver benefits like
mood immune system and sleep support
sustained energy and so much more you
can even get it in convenient travel
packs for when you're on the go like
I've been using out on the live in a
live tour I've also been putting them in
morning shakes now too I've been adding
in that to make sure I get my athletic
Greens in we have them here at the
studio as well my friends are using them
everybody loves them athletic greens is
the real deal y'all so if you want to
take ownership of your health today is a
good time to start athletic greens is
giving you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to
athleticgreens.comhoneydew that's
athleticreens.com honeydew check it out
now let's get back to the do and so and
this is the part I wasn't sure if I was
going to talk about this or not but
yesterday was Father's Day so I'll do it
so Daya I'm in the hospital and they say
you're gonna have to stay here another
five days and I'm losing my [__] mind
I'm uh suddenly I'm just enraged I'm
like no like not more hospital I can't
be in here anymore
then I get a call from my sister
my dad died no unexpectedly while I'm in
there no and they had just told me I
would have to be there another five days
and I'm like my brain just shuts down I
start screaming I'm just like my white
wife comes in like five minutes later
she was just on her way there she finds
me just like
like the ugly crap obvious and she
doesn't know this is she thinks I'm just
in pain and she walks in and she's like
what's wrong what's wrong and I'm just
like my dad died and she's like what the
[__] what's happening to us right now
and I'm just like
it was everything in that moment
collapsed in on me because I'm just
thinking like how did he die he he I
mean he's almost 80. he he fell in the
bathroom they think it might have been
it falls man they think it might have
been like a cardiac or something might
be my dad didn't treat himself super
well over the years he was I mean he was
when he started kind of slowing down he
slowed down pretty hard you know but and
he also did a [__] ton of cocaine over
the years
a massive amount
he told me one time he told me in his
life I asked him this is like a couple
years ago I was like Dad just you know
just so I know look we're we're old
enough here how much cocaine do you
think you've done in your life how much
have you spent and he goes I don't know
000 and I went what holy hell and he's
like he's like yeah I mean I've been
thinking about yeah
yeah probably about that and I was just
like you bought one of probably West
commercials
like you spent enough money on cocaine
that you one of those hippos running
around is a Murray Hooper hippo and it
was and he never once did a psychedelic
never once and I'd like to stop them
from doing the code game I was like you
chose so wrong I hate to tell you that
but you chose so wrong but my dad was
never the person to be introspective he
was never the let me go in there and
think about the way I've like you know
existed for the person might have just
saved your life you're on acid and acids
being like yo I know you're having a
good time here but you might want to get
this next [__] checked out a hundred
percent I attribute the site cocaine
would have been like [__] that yeah
what you want a double dragon the two
hundreds at the same time
I used to call it walrusing when I would
take two spoons at the same time it goes
but yeah it's it's insane so then all of
a sudden I'm like oh so nothing in my
life everything is crashing on me at the
exact same time whereas I've been living
this joyous positive life of abundance
for the past few years now it's all
coming like I was like you start
thinking like did I hit a kid with a car
that I don't know about like did I block
out some horrible thing that I did to a
person like the other thing that's
frustrating too and you can relate to
this is you're in this Hospital not for
lifestyle not for any of that you're
there because your body's got something
going on and your dad now dying also has
nothing to do with you doing anything
wrong either and now you're there for
five more days so you do they have to
hold the funeral and the viewing and
stuff so you can get out the we didn't
even
um so my dad my dad was a very much like
when I die it's over okay don't do
things for me like don't he was it he
hated the term passed away if you said
like oh some of my friend passed away my
dad would go you mean he died like my
dad very much I think he died very
quickly which is exactly what he would
have wanted yeah me too yeah agreed like
he wasn't it wasn't he wasn't all his
kids around him in a bed like Dad you
did so good we love you I would have
liked to have some level of closure
obviously because it was just suddenly
like what what happened yeah and on the
phone my dad do you remember the last
conversation you had with him now when
you you think he's in the hospital I
mean I know that I know it's in the
hospital no he didn't come to see me my
mom visited but he was uh we didn't knew
we didn't know we were gonna I was gonna
be in there nearly that long and you
know he's old enough where traveling is
an ordeal so it wasn't it wasn't like
Dad you need to come out here my mom
flew out because she thought I was gonna
die my dad was like I he's that's not
gonna happen and my dad's one of those
people who masks how he actually is
doing and my wife says I very much have
this quality too where people like are
you okay you're like I'm fine and
meanwhile it's like your leg is bleeding
like profusely and you're like man
whatever my dad's the same way the last
time I talked to him was three days
before he died he sounded like with all
the life in the world he's laughing he's
you know he's like yeah you'll be out of
there soon
yeah so I just didn't I didn't know and
when I got out of the hospital I mean I
remember I don't know what you were like
when you got out but I was crying so
hard when I finally got released that my
wife was afraid I wasn't breathing
properly because I was like
it was the sunniest [__] day December
17 2022 and I was just like yeah yeah
and she's like breathe breathe
and I uh I got emotional because I laid
him like you I laid on my back the
entire time flat and the highest I got
was 30 degrees so when I was able to go
home I asked him I'm like can I roll to
my side and they're like you can roll to
your side and I was like oh and when I
rolled in my side I cried I laid there
and cried
crazy it's unbelievable when it's all
taken away from you you don't realize
the little intricacies of life that you
take for granted on a daily basis and
it's the simple thing of just like oh it
like you're saying it hurts us to roll
over doctors would a team of doctors and
nurses would roll me over to do like
injections and stuff because I was too
weak to do it myself when I got out
because I had the surgery five days
before on my knee I was on a walker and
hopping on one foot and unable to like
real I was attached to an intravenous IV
for the next month so I had to carry
around a fanny pack with me anywhere I
went the tubes kept getting caught on
like kitchen drawers and so like you
know when you're just walking
that would happen to me around my own
house multiple times a day and you worry
because you worry that it's just gonna
rip the cord right out of you
and I didn't do anything basically for a
full month because I didn't to go
anywhere with such it took so much
effort that I was just like [__] it I'll
just be here doing my rehab my physical
therapy all that stuff and I think the
only way I really got through it was the
entire time I would just tell myself
like this is temporary this is not my
life this is temporary you know you're
gonna get through this you know there
will be a day you'll be able to play
tennis again you'll be able to Slackline
again you will be on stage again like
all of the things that make you a person
will come back but you have to believe
they'll come back I've never I dealt
with horrible depression when I was a
kid and people know me as a very
positive Illuminating presence and when
I was in there there were multiple times
I was like pay the [__] check dude
give me the [__] just shoot me up with
too much Dilaudid or something like that
just end it here I don't give a [__] if
this is what it's gonna be moving
forward same I got really angry
um I got really frustrated I was at the
end of my I was like just like what the
[__] is go yeah I get P I yelled at a
nurse me too yeah I raised my voice I
didn't yell I did yell at the people
that were supposed to take my blood and
and went oh for five on finding a vein
after the fifth one I was like get the
[__] out of here and then the lady can't
hurt their boss came in and it was like
you don't have to apologize I was like
no I shouldn't have cussed like that
she's like it's fine yeah like this is
their job all they have to do I became a
hard stick like which is like I was
every time I got blood taking my life I
used to go give blood every couple of
months like and they would always be
like
you don't even need to tie me off dude
and that's all of a sudden I was a hard
sticker because my body swelled up so
much and I had nurses that were
literally like there's tiny ones on the
side
I call them an excavation team because
they would go in there just like no not
in there let's check another corner
and I was just like
I oh I swelled up so much they had to
cut off my wedding ring
cut it off cut it off wow so it got to
the point when it was going I was going
to lose my finger from circular from
lack of circulation if they didn't get
this thing off of me so I get woken up
I'd been in there maybe two and a half
weeks I get woken up it's two in the
morning six nurses are standing around
me and I'm like what's going on here and
they're like we need to get that ring
off and I was like how do we do that and
they hold up this like Black and Decker
style tool and they're like we're
cutting it off and I'm like okay
it took 45 minutes to get to cut the
ring the entire
the hell was a Kryptonite what the [__]
was that titanium thank you basically it
gives me all my superpowers and the
literally and they're going God
's love
I'm like cracking them up and they they
told me one brother you got to stop
making jokes like but that was like I
was able to finally get there again
because the first week I was in the
hospital there were no jokes there was
no smiling there was no anything I was
just just psychotic and so all of a
sudden I'm able to start cracking some
jokes again part of me starts trickling
back in but yeah when they had to cut
this thing off yeah 45 minutes and it
finally snapped and now I just wear this
silicon one that yeah yeah it just don't
care yeah but man I mean just another
one of those things where you're like I
never well never thought this would be
part of my [__] day today everything
in there happens and you're just like I
didn't even realize this was a
possibility in my life yeah and then I
had a rule in there like stop telling me
things that could happen oh man because
they were like well this could be in
good and good and I was like stop yeah I
could stroke you could you could you
could you could you could brain bleed
cook I was like stop yeah and that's
like so you had clots what I had the
what I learned is clots and embolisms
the difference basically is the clot is
of the embolism is like a piece of
something gets in the way I have Palm I
had massive pulmonary embolisms okay so
it's it's fancy for clot right but yes
there's I've had doctors send me photos
and nurses send me photos of what and
and I had a lady at a meet and greet was
like I had the same thing you had you
want to see my clots and I was like no
this is a complete show them to you I go
is it going to make you feel that much
better she's like yeah I go fine she
opened her phone up and they look like
long bloody leeches you know they're
just clots and strings of [__] and
they're just chunks that rip through you
you know and you had them in your brain
how did it make you feel when you did
that though when you saw those pictures
did it make you feel better no it made
her feel better it didn't make me feel
any better like I was like that's but
also I I had seen them already so like
but from a picture of like this is what
they look like from an nurse that sent
them to me and holding him up against a
ruler so you can see just how big these
things really are and how how lucky you
really are yeah how lucky you really are
that it didn't take you out
um because they said they were
uncovering both my lungs and they were
massive and I was like I learned that so
one in three hospital deaths are from
sepsis and one in five people that get
sets that gets up says die from it still
today which is an insane number that's
an insane number to think about modern
medicine and how far we've come and the
things that we can heal instantly and
yet that one for some reason it's still
kind of foreign as to what we do with it
um I mean
it's when I think about that's that's
the thing is people like man cancer
really almost got you it wasn't cancer
that got like it was a side effect from
a surgery to heal the cancer my back
surgery wasn't the problem either it was
the [__] let me lay there for so long
and clotting that almost killed me had
nothing to do with the the back surgery
back surgery put me down but you know
yeah um all right so let's talk about
this now so you get out of the hospital
now yeah and when are you allowed
because now you're a month off of of
Chemo when are you allowed to go back
and start working on attacking this
again so then we basically first had we
had to go through the antibiotic
treatment for the first month I had to
be attached to this intravenous
antibiotic it would give me six doses a
day every four hours it would shoot
another dose into me for like 30 minutes
and they said while I'm going through
that I cannot possibly start chemo again
and so basically every few days I'm
visiting an infectious disease
specialist getting blood work done
sitting on my oncologist to see when we
can start up again and eventually it got
to the point when I could finally get
off the antibiotics uh and take the
fanny pack off and literally like the
day it came off my college was like get
me in there put me in coach I'm ready
and then how long was that layoff two
months about in total because it was a
month in the hospital and then a month
and a half after that it was about two
and a half months that paused it but I
was responding so well to the chemo that
instead of doing 12 treatments total
they said we're only gonna need to do
eight so we can get this out of you in
four more treatments okay and that was
the one a month or one a week one every
two weeks so two so essentially two
months which meant my last one was going
to happen on March 2nd and I when this
year yeah this is only a couple months
ago yeah my wife and I heard that news
and we were like okay so if there we we
trust them we believe them but I also
knew this is going to take a lot of work
from me I can't sit back and just think
like okay the chemo is going to get
through because also I'm not I'm in pain
my knee's still blown up I'm like
everything about me is still not myself
yet I'm I'm hobbling around and I had to
tell myself every day like you better do
the [__] work that they tell you to
do not just physical but cognitive
exercises too because obviously you know
our brains are everything like if we I
was so afraid that I would lose my quick
wittedness my retrieval of words is
actually when they mentioned stroke to
me that's when I thought like oh [__]
because yeah you know my business
manager we talked about and he was like
you should look into disability
insurance and I was like you know how
insurance companies are if I'm in a
wheelchair they're gonna say he can roll
up to a microphone he can roll out on a
stage and they wouldn't be wrong right
they wouldn't be wrong but but when they
said stroke I was like I wouldn't be
able to do my job then dude I've learned
so much about the United system thought
about that though I didn't even that's
why I was like stop saying things that
could could happen oh see I guess with
you and that's the interesting you and I
is I learned that I had had a stroke
after it or so I wasn't even thinking
stroke is a possibility I'm just
thinking the aftermath of how do I get
my brain back now that it's happened
yeah and yeah how do I get my spirit
back how do I how do I find who who I am
at my core is you know I feel like this
I've become this beautiful person I've
done so much work on myself to really
like who I am and now so much of what I
like about myself has been Stripped Away
and I have to rebuild it piece by piece
same dude and that's it's been a long
time to get to this point of being sort
of sort of mentally healthy and trying
to be a good person good dad good all
these things uh but I find that it's
been coming in waves for me so
um getting the special out made me feel
a little better
um going physically being able to go on
tour to promote the special and see
friends and you know made me feel better
caught my uh my daughter called her
first fish with me down in Austin that's
awesome like things start I got to
perform the first time at the mother uh
my first time this year also my first
time was at the mothership
um and then the store and you know
finally getting back on tour like when I
got on tour the
I got two standing ovations at the end
of two of my shows and I've never had
two is Fort Wayne thank you Fort Wayne
Indiana I've never had that at the end
of shows that's the best so these things
are it wasn't like this turn this light
switch so to speak that just I'm back
it's been these incremental like man
hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah but you
know what else sucks too is like I had
been practicing that I have been
practicing gratitude I journaled every
day about being grateful for my health
and my daughter's Health like I didn't
need this reminder yeah I didn't I
didn't mean it I was already there and
now it's made me slow down a little bit
and and sort of take more in for sure
but I didn't need that like hey you
should be you know health is everything
I know it is I knew it was before this
happened you know I didn't need this to
prove to me that I was right you know
that's I mean that's it everyone was
like so do you have like a New
Perspective and appreciation for life
and I'm
it's like
oh my God have you tasted water
I know you drink water but I feel like
this might be have you tasted this like
I mean were you really are you like are
you smelling the flowers Ryan or are you
just letting them pass your butt like
all that [__]
I am trying I was yeah I was doing that
I take pictures of flowers throughout my
day I was doing that yeah I was
appreciating things I don't think I was
going too hard like I didn't need this
as a reminder for me to slow down or any
of that you know I was
I think I was doing a good Pace you know
uh but man I think I was going too fast
you do I do I think I was I think I
spent many many years running to like as
fast as I could thinking like the faster
I run the faster I will get there
um and I just think that's not true
whereas I I have to tell myself this
year my whole thing this year is that be
the tortoise is the tortoise won the
race he was methodical he was paced he
didn't just run by everything and not
look around right there the whole time
not decision and yeah and that's what I
and I think I was the so slow instead he
wins the race bro yep and that's you
when you when you're forced to slow down
all of a sudden and you can't do the
things that make you feel like who you
are then you start to really pick up a
lot of lessons and I told myself when I
got the cancer I was like this isn't
gonna kill me came a lot closer than I
ever thought it would but it's not gonna
kill me so how can I use this to my
advantage because look I have a decent
career but when I make it through cancer
I might have a great career like all of
a sudden I don't know maybe I'll get
like speaking engagements of like you
know cancer I've already gotten cancer
benefits and [__] like that coming to me
but I think all I did was strengthen my
story and become like people look at me
like now like they're like oh you're a
Survivor and I'm like that's a strong
honestly I feel like that's a strong
word for what I am I think I'm just a
person like I'm a person who enjoys
living my life and I wasn't ready to go
yet you know is that a Survivor maybe
but I don't want to be put on some like
pedestal event of health or anything
like that because there's still plenty
of [__] wrong with me oh yeah I mean
there should not be a frame around this
picture of hell
you should just move all past this
picture yeah it's a it's it's a crooked
picture it's still on the wall we got to
straighten it up every once in a while
it's man so now tell me about we get
back into attacking lymphoma and how
long march second comes and are you
clear so Mark Yeah March 2nd came they
waited two weeks three weeks to do a pet
scan uh and when I go though good I'm so
glad you brought this up actually good
question Mr interviewer so when I went
to get my pet scan my wife was like Hey
I'm Gonna Let You Go on your own for
this one and she goes but this guy is
gonna remember you if it's the same Tech
that was there the day you were stroking
out and I was like oh okay she goes he's
a tall black guy and he's like has an
Island accent like Jamaican or something
and I was like okay so when I show up
there this guy checks me and I realize
oh this has to be the guy and I look at
him like and I have no recollection but
I go hey do you remember me and he goes
no and I was like I was in here a few
months ago and I was in a really bad
State and he goes
and I went what and look I'm gonna do
the accent because it makes the story
better okay but he goes I feel like I'm
looking at a ghost man
and I need gas yeah and I went what do
you mean he goes you were in here with a
with a young woman right your wife and I
was like yeah and he goes man that was
the saddest day I've had in 20 years
doing this job and I went why he goes
because I'm looking
at you then think look at your wife
thinking This Woman's about to be a
widow
and she has no idea
and that hit me so hard he's like I
can't even believe I'm looking at you
right now when you were in here I had to
hold you up I couldn't even take you
into the back room I can't believe
you're alive and suddenly I was like
oh
holy sh like that's the most right
that's when when a stranger looks at you
and goes I thought you were dead
ow why didn't my doctors see that that
morning was kind of all I could think
about because I had seen my oncologist
that morning of that first pet scan that
where I was stroking out and they were
like yeah take some food take a viking
and go home take a nap
but this guy thought I was gonna die
what what where did this how did this
all happen but that's the moment where I
literally got home my wife was like you
remember you and I was like yeah
he remembers
yeah apparently I it was that close to
[__] being gone and so I found out
how can I share when it hit me was when
um my I had a surgeon come in and cry
for me
yes the last thing you want no no
surgeon simply crying I say man you I
should not be Consulting you right now
he's like oh my Riot right I was like
I'm just so proud of the work I did in
you I don't want you to go and make it
look like it was my fault you cried I
was like dude what is it serious all
right he's crying yeah and then luckily
a few days later I get the call clean
[__] clean bill and honestly I was
already like in a celebratory mood I had
already booked like a Comedy Central set
that like as that I was about to that I
was about to film and like I really was
like I'm using this I'm gonna tell the
cancer story it's yours it's not the
cancer story it's yours it's my story
yes yeah for sure and figuring that out
in stand up of walking in front of a
crowd and essentially saying at the time
I'm dying right now in front of you and
I'm gonna try to make this funny and
alleviate your concerns as well as my
own it was quite the challenge because I
would watch audiences like squirm well
there's no way you can't not talk about
it I talk about it now there's no way
you can't not and also I'm very
fortunate to have a show with such a
great audience where we can come on here
and talk about this stuff and hopefully
help other people I'ma say this now for
real if you are having any kind of
health issues definitely go get that
stuff checked don't be like should I yes
you should you 100 should for real I
well I thought about when I first got it
you don't need to take acid to tell you
that yeah
you should anyway
um the I thought about it because you go
okay there's two rules I can take this I
can tell people that I have cancer and I
can talk about it I can make jokes about
it or I another Norm Macdonald route and
pretend that I don't have it and deal
with it myself and not let anybody in on
my world but I am a very I'm personable
and vulnerable and I'm a person who
talks about I'm not afraid to talk about
myself and so my Approach right away was
no I can't leave it in here because I
think about like that's that's who Norm
was right Norm was a gambler and Norm
had his own issues Norm didn't need to
talk about himself ever but I think
about
how alone he must have felt times and
maybe that wouldn't matter to him but to
me
I would have felt like I had the secret
that I wasn't telling anybody if anybody
was ever like hey you seem kind of down
are you okay I would have like been
destroyed so that's why I just told
everybody when I got cancer I made a
YouTube video put it out there I told
myself I need to accept help I didn't
want to do a GoFundMe my wife's sister
talked me into it she was like when a
member of a community gets sick the
other people in the community lift that
member up and right now you're that
member and you need to take our help and
I'm glad I did because honestly letting
people in is not something that I've
always been good at because I like to
just take care of things myself I don't
want to burden other people but this was
a moment I said no I need to receive and
I I can stop the giving train for a
while and I have to focus on myself yeah
I'm terrible at that with with I love to
help and then I don't like to accept it
isn't that crazy because we're it's wild
I say I want the whole thing is I say I
want love all the time and then people
were offering it in so many different
ways and I was uncomfortable with almost
every one of them it's it's I think
don't make a fuss to me please part of
our stand-ups of nature is that we want
to do it ourselves yeah right stand up
is such a solo sport that we just think
like no no I'll I'll get it myself but I
think think about my best jokes my
friends have helped me tag those things
and all whenever I do accept help or I
collaborate things get better yeah so
with the feeling of with my health
shouldn't it be the same if other people
if I take in that level of like you know
just
there's the word retrieval thing not
coming back to me but basically just
that level of just like we care about
you we see you I thought about when I
finally opened my phone again because I
didn't look at my phone for three weeks
when I was in the hospital I said I
cannot look at social media I don't want
to I don't want to know what other
people are doing and I don't want
anybody know what I'm doing right now
I finally opened it up and and I had
thousands of messages as you probably
did too like an overwhelming amount and
what I did is I would lay in the
hospital and I would look at the name
and I would think about I would try to
remember that person a memory with them
and I would read it while really trying
to focus on them and think about it and
everyone was this little shot of
dopamine where I'm like oh this person
that I haven't seen in 10 years is
sending me this beautiful message like
that's so kind okay cool great you know
let him in let them in and I really I
really did it helped a lot so now what's
the rest of your year like how often do
you have to go for checkups to make sure
you're good what what happens now every
month I get blood work done through my
oncologist office I actually have an
appointment uh on Wednesday to go get
that done again
um but on top of that I so I had that
happens for the next three years I get
monthly blood work done and then it goes
to every three months uh I believe
for like the next five years or
something like that and then if we get
it at that point if there is nothing in
there then that would be total limits is
that what it is what is it eight years
total and then you're in remission if
you got nothing yeah I think actually
five oh five maybe it's either five or
it's ten I can't remember which but it's
it slows down the testing a lot and that
will now I'm trying to figure out so as
soon as the cancer went away my Eczema
came roaring back and it was one of
those things I did not just [__] beat
cancer I swear to God the eczema was
like ooh there's a bigger problem let's
uh go dormant for a little bit but then
literally as soon as the cancer was
ahead of me the eczema was like hey we
gave you a break but we're we're ready
let me get in there so now I'm doing
like allergy I'm trying to figure out
the root of the eczema now because I was
really hoping that it would just clear
everything out of me and I would have a
fresh you would think chemo would
probably kill everything I don't I'm not
against the thought on that yeah that's
what I was I in meditations I was going
everything gone everything gone fresh
start health-wise but so now it's just a
matter of like you know trying to be as
good to myself as I can so that I can
keep doing my job as that as I want to
do it and living the life that I want to
live the biggest thing is the time
that's taken away from you you know that
month in the hospital it's this you're
never gonna get that back no all those
appointments that we've had that we have
to do all of that stuff it's just like
it's a massive inconvenience and I'm
lucky that I don't work a regular job
that I make my own schedule I wouldn't
right now with physical therapy three
times a week they make me go for medical
massages they make me uh I've got a
cancer appointment this week I have so
many doctor appointments I would there's
no job out there that where I'd be like
I gotta go and they would be like you
you have to quit no yeah no no no I'm so
glad I work for myself yeah and that's
been I mean it really got me through
this period where especially with like a
GoFundMe and stuff like that everyone
was like you just need to chill you need
to relax and you need to heal and I was
like no I still want to like do stuff
and like Jeff Ross told me something
that he I I've never forgotten this he
goes Alex do not let your ambition get
in the way of your healing
yeah and I had to hear that because I
was yeah I was that person was like I'm
gonna walk out of that [__] last
chemotherapy session straight onto a
stage and do a special but let me tell
you this I
yes but I think that's the right mindset
I was certain I was going to kick this
physical therapy's ass I was certain I
was going to get in and out for this
three-hour outpatient procedure back
surgery and then what physical therapy's
ass and be back in it in no time man
I think that's the right mindset you
don't want to go into it being like oh
this is gonna suck and you know you got
it but but then you do have to temper
real expectations and be like all right
I'm I'm alive we made it through this
now I really am I'm trying my hardest
every day to just be like just focus on
these 24 hours yeah then when I get up
tomorrow we're gonna be the best person
we can those 24 hours yeah I'm trying
that's so important it's hard though
when you when you do it like this
because you got and with a kid you know
and you want to have a family you gotta
you're always looking ahead of they're
going to camp this week and that what
time does it start and that's starting
it where are we going here there cancer
put a weird pressure on me like where
now I feel like okay but now I have to
do more like with my life and if I don't
there's some bigger meaning or purpose
yeah and I don't I don't know and
whether that's true or not my brain is
going like Alex you just don't waste
time like don't just sit around all day
like reading a book like don't do this
like and I'm like but I also
I need to be good to myself and I can't
rush into the rest of my life because
there is still so much more to go and
there's that weird pressure of like okay
I know I'm gonna beat cancer so what can
I do after that to utilize it so I can
be a better person and have you know in
every way and it kind of puts a weird
surviving puts a weird pressure on you
in that in that state and that is the
place where I do feel like a Survivor
where I'm like oh I don't know what to
do now because I had this I never had
this feeling of fragility before but I
do now and I'm not exactly sure the best
thing to do to move forward but I think
that's just going to come with time and
patience dude thank God I'm glad you're
okay
real I know you've got a long road ahead
of you but I'm glad you're okay today
yeah thanks man I appreciate it thank
you thank you for coming on and sharing
the story being vulnerable and you know
what we do over here this is your first
time so advice now after everything
we've talked about today you would give
to 16 year old Alex Hooper first of all
16 year old Alex Cooper would have said
shut up old man who kind of looks like
me [__] you you don't know anything like
he would have been a [__] [__] to
whoever tried to give advice I know that
for sure
um but the main thing is is focus
what I would have wanted to get through
to my 16 year old self is like the world
is not against you and if you can just
realize that you have a place in it and
you can lead with love instead of with
just rebellious spirit that is inside of
you there is a way to move forward that
will service you and I think as a 16
year old I never would have under I
didn't understand that at all that there
I didn't think there was a future but
just like tell them to calm the [__]
down a little bit and just be patient
and fight focus on the things that you
truly enjoy and I think that's what has
gotten me to where I am if I can like
you said gratitude and just focusing on
the things that do make me happy it
really changes every single day I wake
up and I'm like there's opportunity out
there yeah and I don't know when things
are going to change drastically for
worse or for better so I better just
appreciate what the [__] going on
right now if I feel good about it yeah
yeah well said nice um please plug and
promote everything one more time uh yeah
so uh Comedy Central set is dropping on
August 9th uh my podcast is dirty briefs
It's weekly it's super short uh go
listen to it if you like my voice and uh
yeah Hooper comedy.com for all those
tour dates go get it everybody awesome
thank you very much uh as always Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media get those tickets come out
and see me on tour all tickets at
ryancicler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign